i wouldn't say the world needs to know  more about you because they know a lot  about you but they need to see you  through the lens of your wanting to be  helpful as opposed to you're just  wanting to stir the pot yes i don't want  to stir the pot i don't particularly  mind controversy so i'm not adverse to  stirring the pot but no i just want  people to not suffer as much as they do  life is so hard like if you're not  actively suffering you should just  rejoice just party it up that day  like yay i'm not suffering today and so  any way to reduce that amount of  suffering that's what dad's trying to do  too he does sometimes get quoted as  saying empathy is bad but he's so  compassionate it's crazy like when he  has people come up to him on the street  saying you know your work has helped me  he'll just cry because he feels things  like so it's definitely not about  controversy it's about trying to you  know do what you think will reduce  suffering in the world